i want to know whether we can teach
design thinking to a group of
non-designers and innovate in the
education system
it's a two-day workshop where we are
learning about design thinking in order
to solve real world education problems
so prototypes like a sketch they're just
a representation of an idea and when we
think about innovation it's both a
technological innovation but it's also
needs to be innovation around teamwork
and professional learning communities
and thinking together
how can we reimagine what a school
should be in the 21st century we have
empathy building community service what
is the role of online learning what is
the role of collaboration so just
discuss
and vote if we need to how do we come
together as people from very diverse
backgrounds and think about solutions
for education
we have professors teachers students
children we have policy makers
the stakes are changing so fast that
educators have not been able to keep up
when you can break it down and tell it
to a five-year-old or a ten-year-old
like the ones that we have here today
then that is when you really know your
material
we had specific workshop modules i would
teach them a thing or two they would go
back into their teams and implement that
it's a really interactive process it's a
very proactive process really forces you
to think in ways that you may not have
thought before
design thinking is really a kind of
blending of the scientific method and
create a process and we're gonna have
things inside what's great about is it
really breaks it down to these such
simple actionable steps it starts with
some brainstorming
goes through some iterations of like
okay can we narrow down all these ideas
that we're coming up with so you have a
kind of observation empathy research try
to frame the problem work through a
series of prototypes which are
equivalent to the experimentation and
then test those results and see if they
match up with the hypothesis
one of the things we are pitching an
online advising platform for students in
lower income neighborhoods who may or
may not have access to
quality counseling and career and life
advice services
there's this huge interest in food
trucks and science trucks and a space
where you could track where it is and
you could rate it how many of you've
ever eaten at a food truck everything
that we've been doing in two days is
going to be reduced to two minutes for
people using and learning from these
educational mobile trucks they need to
know what will you learn what's the
value of learning this way and what are
reliable reviews of the best trucks out
there so are you considering any ad
service as a truck we're sort of
anticipating a market for ed mobile
trucks but
the prices are reimbursable stipends for
your project development is the
innovation creative is it feasible does
it include multiple perspectives it's a
place where teachers students and
professionals who are living in the
community
i'm hoping we win because
i would like to be the youngest
entrepreneur ever that would be fun you
all uncovered some big themes
um the need to collaborate i like how
much every group got a real good handle
on the design process i thought the
energy was great i really enjoyed the
creativity and i am a convert to trucks
i mean i love food trucks but there are
so many trucks so basically there are
mobile physical things that are going to
happen in education i learned that this
afternoon thank you all